hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep the
babies back baby plier mark a baby and I
know what you'd call me but I'm here and
apparently I'm probably gonna die okay
so is there any way that I could lift
this okay that's gonna twitch a little
bit but can I lift this up here I'm an
ingenious baby and I know how leverage
and physics works come on well the baby
I can't lift up that barrel it was just
come on what if I really needed that to
make it through this puzzle it's not
really a puzzle I just need to get up
there but come on your son maybe I oh I
get it
that barrel was too tall I'm just a sure
little baby why would I have been able
to get up that barrel let me get the key
and then this is gonna allow me to get
out of here I think that's not a good
sound
I'm a baby but I know how to do this Oh
lady how are you doing lady
you look good look better than good you
look great
you look so good I can't even imagine
how good you look you still out there
did you take another dive in the water
Hey thank you don't know why these
boards are still here but I just Toph ed
through them Oh baby power died that was
me breaking it thaws Emiel maybe I
should shut up with the stupid jokes and
just carry on my way I actually don't
know which way I'm supposed to go I kind
of got lost here those um these misty
woods they're easy to get turned around
it but I'm assuming I'm supposed to go
that way and let's set her down there
that's okay
sudden silence is just as bad look
Elijah now I was wondering when things
were gonna get creepy I'm glad that that
time that is now is happening okay no I
think this is the way that I came so I
need to go this way I say with an
uncertain tone what is over here I
wonder Oh death God the sudden stoppage
of noise is very disconcerting I'm just
assuming I need to go back careful cause
I'm a baby
I forgot sometimes it's very easy to
forget that I'm actually a two-year-old
and I'm not supposed to be in this
environment but here I am
I hear splits fly
oh dang by mark oh come on you baby
bastard get on your feet
is the last time that I'll be yelling at
a little child to hurry the F up so what
I need to do I think I need to speak
faster unless this is just a fool's
errand then this is just leading into my
death which could be as high priority
I'm just clouds of spit everywhere in
this pit maniac right now googoo gaga
but just a baby I see you there's a
crocodile what are you doing crying for
your mommy I should be the one crying
for my mommy are you my mommy are you my
mommy lady my mom is not dead though so
that might be a little bit problematic
to that hypothesis
okay just sneaking right by okay so
maybe at this juncture I went left when
I was supposed to go right I do not know
I have a square key now I open the
triangle door before oh there is okay
I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm solid I'm
rock solid I am a okay I'm in it to win
it I am the bee's knees I'm the baby of
Oz : go goddamnit got open no that's
wrong
hello baby have a baby don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me don't kill me
God that was the most terrifying figures
she still by me she still I'm isn't it
[Music]
we we all ignore the fact that that was
probably the highest pitched scream I've
ever done in my entire life cool don't
like that that is in fact pretty bad
okay
the beginning of the Mario 64 portal
system so I'm just gonna hop back
Kukoc damn it that was his video zero
that actually sounded like cuz I know
it's gonna be bad but all right so these
are the last puzzle piece teddy bear
he's definitely not gonna betray me at
the end of all this I'm just gonna carry
on my way oh no I gotta go through
another painting into another demon wall
Arnie why do they know our faces this is
a lovely slender family before they were
violently torn from each other's arms
baby rock star oh god damn it's gonna be
another area of nightmares I need to
collect it two more memories overall I
don't know how long this game actually
is I think some people were saying that
it's actually a short game but I don't
know maybe I'm just taking longer to get
through it
at least see what happens is there any
dastardly demons our bear in the
darkness I used the deal iteration of it
too much so malevolent maniacal monsters
mashing out in them mmmm bleah more
growth woods and woods in the woods
baby don't kill baby no kill little baby
no no somebody feet oh no little baby no
kill how could even see me she he she he
I don't know whatever you call yourself
I will respect your life choices okay
okay how that have she can actually kill
me maybe she's not really a threat
although I have a distinct feeling that
she's probably a very large threat can I
climb up okay can't climb up on that
because it's not gonna let me all right
cool that's cool
a my dad might be dead does that do
okay I was worried that when I click the
pacifier I might have just boy this kid
he gets knocked down yeah you usually
punch a baby in the face and he just
goes down stays down to this one you get
him he gets back up he's he's got the
eye in a tie yet get away from this lady
not though I want to clarify not that
I've had much experience in baby
punching but it'd be too different than
like any normal punching of small
creatures of small stature
about it really
dryads give me what I cover my hands or
my eyes when I answer I'm dead that is
that is that is my middle name
what is that what's going on where am i
what happened
this bad is going poorly for me I need
to find a better way to get around her
without going straight into her gullet
okay so I just gotta crawl on my belly
it's got to be very sneaky about all
this it's gotta be the stealthy of baby
that ever lived
I'm a shadow crawling
what did I do
where I get it I'm running I'm out of
here if you're going around that way I'm
I'm just assuming Oh God
okay don't know what happened to the
first one but okay whatever okay just
gonna run this way
still go for it going for it baby on the
run maybe on the run don't know where
I'm going don't know what I'm doing now
baby I thought I fall in the river there
you're not dead yet get up son hit him
with the old one-two
I hope I don't need to actually find
anything in this library because I'm
going to be very dead very soon if I
have to go in a circle
is this a correct path did I make it
sir memo reunir sir a memo read can I
close this damn door thank you no one
heard this close very silent yeah okay
look about the five drowning friends
[Music]
cool that's a great story mom now if you
could stop being dead I could carry on
with my life
all right cool oh hi hi there demon lady
how would you like to go away forever
and fall into a pit of hell it's great I
got great makings baggage of free right
now what was that song you were humming
mother er if it really is you and if
you're not really the teddy bear who's
trying to get my goat goddamn you are I
went through all the death did you I
don't trust you very much god damn it's
like one of those some of the scariest
chases I've ever been through
who's terrifying amplified by the fact
that I am a freaking baby anything like
what what are you look at how shouldn't
that's what I was saying oh my god we
understand each other so much this is
amazing thank you miss be so nice we can
play together all the time that's okay
I was Green with you before but now it
sounds distinctly evil what you're
saying no much care for evilness here so
how about you doing I'm just gonna burn
all my memory hmm hmm he's gonna burn
all my memories up and trap them in this
machine oh hi hello there with your
beady little eyes staring at me okay
crank it I'll close it first then crank
it sorry it's been almost a day since I
was playing this last the key is to very
gently turn it that way I don't have to
do the big motions
is that a good thing that you can feel
my mother that also sounds slightly
sinister do not that you're saying
you're saying yeah you keep saying these
things that why all right here we go mr.
teddy bear I'm gonna go and see the next
area but then I'll have depth in the
episode there he keeps saying these
things that are somewhat comforting but
in another level they're also very not
comforting
goodbye everybody fell in this hole
because I'm a little kid it's like going
down the rabbit hole like Alice in
Wonderland yep my name is I don't know
what my name is actually good that was a
nice soft landing on my baby bones what
have we got here what are we dealing
with this time sky what is that what is
that am I looking at here whoa um tells
me this place isn't too friendly I don't
know what the hell that is but I guess
I'm gonna find out on the next episode
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that games that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]